daniela compro papas en el mercado y
pago
séptimos de dólares por dos novenos de
libras vamos a marcar los dos novenos de
libras
si las papas tienen un costo de rd
dólares por cada libra vamos a marcar
los r dólares
este es otro dato importante por cada
libra que los manejaremos como dólares
sobre libra de información de la
siguiente es verdadera para los posibles
valores de p y r vamos a seleccionar
todo lo que aplica y aquí con estos
datos podemos saber que si yo tengo una
cantidad x de producto que en este caso
fue 2 novenos y que si por ellos pagamos
un precio que está establecido que en
este caso fue r tendremos entonces el
precio total que hemos pagado por esta
cantidad de producto que si lo vemos en
nuestros datos son p sobre 7
en este caso nos están solicitando tener
la información para p y para r y en las
respuestas tenemos la solución para p la
solución para el primero vamos a
despejar p para saber si tenemos
información adecuada al respecto
si nosotros tenemos esta información
pues podemos ver que nada de esto es lo
que tenemos en las respuestas así es que
vamos a manipularlo de tal manera que
tengamos primero pe para que nosotros
podamos despejar la p lo que vamos a
hacer es multiplicar por 7 a ambos lados
de la ecuación
y de esta manera se cancelan estos siete
y tendremos pe de este lado
y del lado izquierdo tendremos 7 por 2
es igual a 14
no vemos que están multiplicando a r
y con esto tenemos el despeje de p vamos
a ver si alguno de estos despejes no se
incluye p de tal manera que tengamos
esta información p es igual a 14 novenos
por r es exactamente esta misma
información sólo que está al revés se
dan cuenta
pero es correcto dado que aquí podemos
considerar que 14 novenos r está
multiplicando a 14 novenos por r así es
que seleccionaremos esta primera casilla
como dato correcto o verdadero vamos
ahora a despejar r y para que podamos
despejar a r multiplicaremos ambos lados
de la ecuación por 914 amos
así es que multiplicaremos por 9 14 a
bosch de igual manera que aquí
multiplicaremos por 9 14 a 2 y con esto
se cancelan
y tendremos entonces r es igual a p por
914 abós tenemos algo así bueno
definitivamente no es esta y si tenemos
9 14 a vos por p es igual a r por lo que
también seleccionaremos esta segunda
opción como respuesta correcta
finalmente vamos a saber si este despeje
de 14 novenos es igual a p por equis
tomaremos entonces la versión original
que teníamos aquí 14 novenos por ere
será igual a pp y lo reescribir de este
lado
14 no vemos que están multiplicando a r
serán igual
y para que nosotros hagamos el despeje
de 14 novenos lo que haremos es dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre r de
tal manera que se cancela la r de este
lado y se divide
/ r y con eso tenemos el despeje de 14 9
y 14 novenos es igual a p / r no por r
de tal manera que ésta tampoco es una
respuesta válida con eso solo tendremos
estas dos casillas seleccionadas como
respuestas adecuadas